- [Mark] All right, Sharp
- Sure.
- [Mark] Welcome back.
- Thank you for having me back Mark.
- [Mark] So here we are in Atlanta
Player's Ball tonight.
- Good old ATL,
Players ball tonight.
- [Mark] Word is you might get the
Pimp of the year this year.
- So they saying (laughing)
- [Mark] You probably deserve it.
You probably deserve it.
- What'd you think
Mark, do you think I do.
- [Mark] I think you do.
I don't know the game like you,
like some of these guys do,
but your personality certainly deserves
something crazy like that.
- Right. Well, in this game
if you want it for real,
you gotta do it for real,
and that's just how
I move in my life, man.
I wanna do things for real.
So, cause I want real
things in my life, man.
I don't want nothing fake.
I don't want nothing funny
So I come to what's real.
This is my reality.
This is my reality, man.
I move around.
I'm glad that you came Mark, this as fun.
This one is fun, man.
To even have you here.
- [Mark] Yes,
- It is, man.
What do you wish your
experience is to it so far?
Like you said, you've never been,
involved like that to know.
So what is your, what's your
experiences here so far?
What have you experienced that you will--
- [Mark] And just a room
full of charismatic men.
A few of the girls I've dressed and ready
but so far it's the afternoon still
it's mostly just bunches of
the players that are here and
they're all interesting personalities.
Every one of them
- Most definitely
They're good friends of mine, man.
They all good people, man.
Good souls, good souls.
- [Mark] It's interesting how the,
you can say that the game is
bad, if you are for square
what you guys do is illegal and it's bad.
It's a simplistic view.
But it's interesting
how a lot of the guys,
you like them, they're really likable,
like yourself.
They're very likable personalities.
And they talk about the
Lord and they talk about,
God and all the other things they do
for the community that are good.
So it's a weird and
interesting mix of good and,
what we a lot of people perceive as bad.
- Well, you know, it's a--
- [Mark] I mean, it's not really, I mean
tell me your take on,
I've met a couple of your girls
and they don't complain.
They're not unhappy with their situation.
the last time you were by
you brought one of your
ladies with and she was
bragging about how much money she's making
and how (laughing),
how great her life is.
- I'll say this man.
I love the game still, man.
I'm not changing it.
I'm not trying to revamp it.
I'm not trying to,
I want it to be as real as
this room that we're in.
I want it to be as real,
And a lot of people sit there and say, Oh
he talks a lot of bullshit or,
he runs in circles.
Hey man, I'm telling you all the truth.
If you really listen,
read between the lines,
I'm not telling nothing that's phony,
and if there's anybody
that could take some
of my words, man, and apply them
to their everyday life, why not?
What, because I am who I am.
That's the problem?
That's why they don't want to apply it,
but deep down inside, they go try it
and they say, fuck man, it worked.
It's okay, man.
Some of us all do have
more ambition than others.
And it's okay for us to
rub some of that off.
That is okay.
There is nothing against the law
that says that I can't come
and give some people
some news they can use.
It's been crazy, man.
It's been a crazy year with COVID,
and people just running
around acting crazy.
It ain't been people like myself
running around acting crazy.
It's the people they done
gave all the money to
that was stealing.
It's not us, man.
And this isn't a,
hey get out of jail free card or hey,
look at me I'm a victim.
I'm not a victim to anything,
I'm not a victim.
And nor am I trying to victimize anybody
not trying to make that kind
of impact on anybody's life.
I want it to be all positive.
- [Mark] I think a lot
of the confusion with you
is your style of communication,
is kind of indirect
but you just answered
the question I asked.
But it wasn't like a one sentence answer.
You went here and there
and you moved around
- My mind runs a million
miles an hour, man.
Even when I'm laying there going to sleep
I'm running my mind a
million miles an hour, man.
I can't stop thinking.
Thinking is good for the soul,
so it's okay to think,
it's okay to overthink.
It's not okay to under-think.
You can't do yourself like that, man.
You gotta believe.
If you, let me ask you this, Mark
If you don't believe in you, who will?
(Mark laughing)
Who will believe in you?
You can't ask the next
door fucking neighbor
to believe in you if he don't see you
believing in yourself every day.
- [Mark] It's all us.
- It's all, it starts with you.
Just like it starts with me.
just like it starts with
a lot of those other
charismatic people that you said
that you have had the
blessings of encountering with.
They just need to stop
knocking the real man.
This is very real.
Real people, I'm still a real person.
I think just like the
next person thinks, Mark.
I do.
I don't think that I'm
out here just trying to
hurt people and go crazy,
even though that's everybody's,
that's how everybody looks at me.
That's everybody's mode is,
Oh, he's a fucked up individual.
Oh, he's running them down in the ground.
He's got them on drugs.
I don't do drugs.
Sorry to bust your bubble.
Drug-free program up over here.
I went to DARE.
It worked for me.
(laughing)
- [Mark] And I met one
of your girls last time.
I think I've met two of your girls
and they were happy and
had good things to say about their lives.
And I didn't detect any kind of
strange things going on.
- Oh, no you don't know
- [Mark] (laughs) good answer.
- I don't, but
I don't know
I like coming and hanging
out with you, man.
It's like where I get to
come and confess my sins,
Or confess my truth rather.
- [Mark] What do you worry about?
What's your biggest fear?
- My biggest fear is not
being who I really want to be
or waking up.
That's why I think I don't do it.
That's why I know.
Excuse me.
That's why I know I don't do
drugs or try to have any type
of serious vices because
I've always been afraid.
Always been, yeah, me not afraid.
I've always been afraid of getting up
looking in the mirror and
not recognizing myself.
So that's why I'd never gotten
lost like that in the sauce.
Yeah. Drugs have always been around me.
I mean, drugs comes, I
think with anybody's life
hell you could be a politician
and be into drugs heavy.
So it doesn't really
matter what walk of life,
it's just about the type
of person that you are.
I'm a firm believer in that Mark.
I really am, man.
I really am be who you are.
That's the only thing that
I'm really afraid of, man.
It's just, I don't want to wake
up one day and not recognize myself.
- [Mark] I think believing
in yourself as you do.
And as I do,
keeps you from ever
wanting to comfort yourself
with advice like drugs or alcohol
or gambling or whatever
you know is missing.
- You got to look at your life
like you're already winning.
- Yeah.
- That's why I don't gamble.
And people ask me,
I'm going through casinos all the time.
You see people gambling or,
dealers at tables, that'll see me a lot,
And they'd be like, Hey man
why don't you come over here
and spend a couple of bucks?
Come on, man.
Come win something
and I'll stop and tell them,
hey man, I'm already winning.
And keep pushing, I'm already winning.
I don't need to go and
spend my money with it.
Make me feel like I'm going
to, Oh, let me go try to win.
No, I'm already winning.
I know where the sure winnings are.
- [Mark] Have you always
recognized as I have that
when everyone is doing something
that's usually an indicator
that it's something to do avoid.
(interviewee laughs)
I saw that early on and like
everyone's doing something.
I think they're all wrong.
- Yeah.
- [Mark] I'm just going to
stand back and sure enough
every single time they're always wrong.
- They're always wrong.
You always watch them go
to their own failures.
They create their own failures, man.
- [Mark] Yeah. You have
to think for yourself.
- You have to man.
Listen, I haven't been around all types
of walks of life,
different types of entities
of people wanting to do
from man companies, drugged.
I don't care what it is I've been in.
I've never changed me.
I've always been the same person
and they've always loved
me or like me for who I am.
I've never had to change.
They're going to change my persona
or the person that I am ever.
It's just the people that hide
behind this camera that start getting
in those funky ass
comments that want to hide.
It's not people that I've ever met.
Like people say, oh,
I couldn't stand to be
in a room with them for five minutes.
You've never been in a room
with me for five minutes.
And you wouldn't really know.
- [Mark] I mean,
you turn on your personality
and into overdrive on camera
but in person you're a
little more laid back.
- I mean, come on.
- [Mark] You're very good.
- Listen when I get on
camera, I've got a lot to say.
It's a lot my mind starts racing.
So, it's hard to let it out, man.
It's hard to let all this is on now.
- [Mark] (laughs)
I mean, for those that don't,
- I'll get tongue tied sometimes
- [Mark] For those that are
wondering what you're all about.
You're not like this all the time 24/7.
- [Mark] Yeah.
- No,
- [Mark] you're turning it on
for the camera a little bit.
A little bit. Not a lot.
- Not a little bit man.
Listen to me.
This, people have to understand this,
Isn't a character.
This is really who I am.
- [Mark] No, absolutely
- This is really me.
When the cameras go off, I
still speak the same way.
Maybe not as firm because
when I'm sitting here
in front of this camera,
man, I don't know.
Who's about to watch this.
Who's gonna see this.
So you know what I'm going to speak from?
And I'm going to speak like a man should.
- [Mark] I have no doubt
that at whatever hour in
the morning you wake up.
This is who you are before
you have your coffee. (laughs)
This is who you are
- Man. I listened to me, man.
I'm old school man.
Structure imbalance is everything to me.
I still get up.
Mop my floors.
I still do my dishes.
I still keep a clean household.
I was telling a buddy of mine downstairs.
I was like, if you wake up and,
and this is to anybody, right?
If you wake up in a shady environment
sheets thrown everywhere.
Shit fucked up the room smells.
How do you think your
personality is going to be
during that day?
Your aura, your persona.
How do you think it's going to be?
It's going to be shady.
It's going to be everything
that was in that room.
But if you wake up and everything's clean
and everything smells good.
Let me give what you're going through.
Wake up in a clean environment.
Structure in balance is key.
It helps the mental man.
It really does.
No matter what you're
going through, we all go
through Shemin people lose
their entire families.
Fuck it, don't wake up in
a fucked up environment.
Cause it'll fuck your mind up.
You're already dead.
You might as well go join along.
I've missed this.
This is all.
This is the best right here.
And (laughs)
- [Mark] How many fighters
balls have you been to?
- Ah, fuck man.
I start going to him and,
maybe oh five or four or five.
And let me stop you there.
So it's always been my
friends though, man.
I grew up around a lot of these guys.
I grew up around him as a kid man.
So they know me.
I'm not star struck by any
of it and they're not star struck by me.
We've always all been friends.
- [Mark] (mumbles)
- Just one of the boys, man.
That's it just one of the boys man.
Part of the church you did.
Yeah. Yeah.
It's a beautiful thing, man.
- [Mark] So a lot of
people that watch my videos
or watch your video respond
to you strongly, they say Tim
for president (chuckles)
2024 and all this kind of crazy stuff.
Have you always had this magnetism
- From people
- [Mark] Just from people that meet you
or know you or go to
school with or whatever?
- No, because I think,
and I'm not going to say everybody
but you have to understand more.
Everybody's starting to
get their their selves.
They don't want to slow down
for a second and say, Hey
you're the man makes them feel
like shit, that makes any sense.
Kind of makes them feel like, shit man
just sit there and say, hey,
everybody's trying to get
on everybody, man, everybody
they ain't gonna tell me I'm doing right.
And they not.
And they know who it is.
So that Part of it doesn't
even, it doesn't even phase me.
I don't even think about
that nor do I want to
because it comes with
ugly things from people.
Even if you're living in it
you have to think about it, man.
You going just say you work a regular job.
You're the best of it.
All of them know you're the best of it.
They rather try to watch
you to do something
fucked up to get you fired.
And they come and say, hey Mark
you did a fucking outstanding job.
We know you're the best here.
- [Mark] You think most people
like want to knock you down
- Never but you know what?
I've been knocked down
or people have attempted
to try to knock me
down an outside life.
More than in this one.
There's nothing but love and peace
and harmony in this from
the people that I know.
- [Mark] Do you find you get that kind of
into those kinds of conflicts
with people often your personality is big.
- Oh yeah man, I bump heads
with people all the time
but as long as we got
a clear understanding
that I'm me, you're you, here's the line.
And I guess this is where we part ways.
I'm okay with doing that with people
not everybody's for you,
not everybody's your friend.
I love watching people run
around doing that shit.
This is my friend. This is my friend.
What have you and your friend really have?
Have you ever went
through what they would
call a traumatic bond?
Like, fuck it.
It's not always good times.
You know what I'm saying?
When something really fucked up happens.
Does that person still
stand in your corner?
- [Mark] Sometimes you go through hell
- Or do they fold on you?
Do they hold or do they fold
One person that holds man at all costs
- [Mark] But what rules do you live by or
what things do you believe
deeply that you live by?
Like for me, for example, it's
there's an easy way to do things
and there's a really
difficult way to do things.
And what I've learned
is this difficult ways
of doing things will bring about the
the optimal result, the better result.
And that's what I want.
So I'm willing to work
as hard as I need to.
- Well, I'm a person that,
I've always believed in
working smart and not hard.
I've always been a firm believer
in that man,
and telling truth to the
people that are around me.
I listen
if you're not doing what
I'm doing mentally, mentally
I can't fuck with you.
I can't.
You have to have a mindset on you.
That's out of this world.
I grew up around old school ways.
So I still obtain those ways,
that structure, that balance.
That is key to me.
That is, that is what makes sharp run.
That's what keeps me moving baby
is being able to, you know what?
People need to stop trying
to control what they
can't control
and start trying to control
the things they can.
That's all I did, baby.
I got smart.
And I learned to control that things I can
- [Mark] what would you say to this?
There's something else
I believe in fear is a
a guide or a compass of what you
- Very much so. Very much so
- [Mark] whenever you're
afraid of something
that's usually exactly what you should do,
- Right, I've listened, man.
We've all, we all got fears.
We all do.
No matter how strong my
voice may say, hey man
we all got fears.
You got fears.
The viewers, they got fears,
but it's about really facing
the belly of the beast, man.
That's what makes you strong.
Sometimes you got to learn the hard way it
makes you who you are.
It's okay to get smacked on
the ass every now and again
and real and getting a little pinch to
and let you know you're
alive and you are living.
It's okay for any of us to get that.
Even including myself.
It's great for us.
It's healthy for us
mentally and physically (Mark mumbles)
All the fucking time.
You know what I was thinking, right?
And I really feel this way.
People go watch, soft, white underbelly.
And they get on there.
And they wake up that morning.
They might not be feeling
the best about their life.
So they go and they, let
me go look at this person.
Well, this person's
life's a little bit more
fucked up than mine.
So I guess I don't have to feel as bad.
Even though these are people's real lives
that you're sitting
there feeling better on.
You're feeling better on their shittiness.
And then when you find a
person like me, charismatic
standing strong, probably
eating more than you.
You find a problem with that.
So then they start to hate
and then the hatred just grows even bigger
and bigger to where you
can't even put the flame out
- [Mark] But the hate
and a lot of these kinds
of situations is ending.
It's just envy.
Look at you.
You're charismatic.
You're handsome.
You're,(chuckles) you're outspoken.
You're easy to hate for,
especially for a male.
- Hey man.
You know, what's so cold though
is, cause I don't hate them.
- [Mark] No I know
- I don't hate anything.
I don't hate anything about the next man.
- [Mark] No, you don't take it as
it's not a competition against
- it's never been a competition.
When Were we ever racing?
I thought this was a
marathon.(Mark laughs)
When were we ever in the
fucking amazing race?
I don't understand this part of it.
I don't want to compete with the next man.
Not trying to sit outside
in that pissing contest
waiting to see who the fuck can
piss the furthest, I'm cool.
- [Mark] It's hard enough
to deal with your own shit
- Man. I'm good, Man
I'll go use the toilet.
I'll go to the bathroom.
I'm fine.
I'll pass.
- [Mark] What's been the
hardest thing you've gone
through in your life.
- Not having my kids with
me every day, every second.
That's being honest, man.
And it ain't a
that has got anything to
do just with the game.
That's just life because
I really love him.
I think that's the,
that's the roughest thing is not
having them there every day.
And every time they come
and they get ready to leave
I think that reality sinks
back in, you know what I mean?
Does that make sense?
I think that reality starts to settle back
in that, hey, they're going on?
That this is how it is.
- [Mark] I'm divorced.
And I have two daughters.
- So, you know how it goes, you know
just with kids and not
having them there every day.
You know what I'm saying? It's,
and people have to understand,
your harp on fathers and things like that.
You have to understand
nobody's going to be there
a hundred percent not living in the house
but these women wants you
to be 100% entertaining.
Everything that they got going
on, it's kind of hard to do.
I don't live with you. I'm not with you.
And I'm speaking this
from just a general
standpoint, not with you.
So how the fucking can I be there 100%?
they'll never be happy ever
but I think that's something that
me and maybe people like
yourself, we're willing to accept.
It's okay.
I mean, we ought to
- [Mark] Do your best.
- Got to do your best.
Love you, Mark.
I love coming to hang out
with you, man, it's fun
- [Mark] Likewise
- It's fun man, we out here
in Atlanta, what's up, man.
We gonna have a drink tonight and what?
- [Mark] Here we are
- Come on, man. We're going to celebrate.
It's a celebration am I right?.
- [Mark] We're going to be
celebrating that trophy.
I think you're going to get man.
- Let's do it.
Come on, man.
I'm going to let you
hold it. (all laughing)
- [Mark] All right. We got some fun today.
- We're gonna have some fun man.
Thank you for having me once Again.
- [Mark] Thanks for coming by here.
- Thank you, too.
- [Mark] We'll do many more of this.
- Yes we will.
- [Mark] All right, man.
- Cheers
- That was cool. That was good
That was just like a, i like (mumbles)